[Music]
good afternoon everyone
welcome to the talk about the fifty
years ago when I first left China to
come to the United States to attend
graduate school at Virginia Tech um
little bit excited but also with a lot
of uncertainty
I worried if I can adjust the culture
here I worried if my English could be
understand by other people because of my
isn't after I come to the state and meet
all these awesome people I found out my
experience is as much as I could imagine
likewise no matter if we nice your first
time to run circles over or Mike reading
your existing circles of a workload to
the Google cloud I hope your experience
will be just as smooth as my our top end
price Kozma often surprised to learn
that Google underlying infrastructure is
the best place to run your existing
enterprise workload Windows and the
second server is no exception
today I'll be talking about the run
Microsoft cycle silver on cocoa can be
the engine just a little bit about
myself my name is fun mean I'm the tech
lead for the windows team at the Google
compute engine my team work on a lot of
different area from the Pierce device
driver to the host hypervisor from the
BIOS firmware to the win32 user and the
service we want to make sure our
customer to able to run a secure server
in the Windows virtual machine host by
the Google compute engine we want it to
be performing secure and reliable here's
the rough agenda for today in the
beginning we all go with a history about
the windows and the circle server on
Google compute engine we are talking
about how to create and configure secure
server instance we will go over some
performance improvement which is
critical for the success of a workload
I've let my colleague any bar will go on
stage to talk about how to deploy second
server always on a very big group using
the PowerShell with the interesting
light-filled demo after demo we were
talking about the story in a backup and
wheelchairs and tip and the best
practice for the disaster recovery and
also for the performance tuning so our
journey for the witches windows and the
circus ever start a little bit over two
years ago when we launched Windows
Server 2008 r2 support Google compute
engine in the end of the 2014 in summer
2015 we announced the general
availability for the Windows Server on
GCE including the support for the
Windows Server 2008 r2 and the 2012 r2
moving into the 2016 we add support for
the second server standard and a second
server web Edition immediately after
Microsoft announced over the breeding
for the windows 7 2016 within a week
Google cloud platform was able to launch
the support for the 2013 on the Google
compute engine it demonstrated the kudos
commitment for the enterprise customer
early this year we add a support for the
sickle server enterprise including
always all over the British group of
support so why do I think it's a good
idea to bring your second server
workload to TC first GCE is a powerful
platform which has a lot of advanced
feature which would really power up your
second server
we support VSS integrated PD snapshot it
bring the data consistency of your
snapshot to the application consistent
together with the butene sikozu backup
support it makes it very powerful to to
make sure take your backup and where the
instance is running without the
interrupted with support sticker Server
Enterprise Edition which the always-on
cross beam support allowing you to
configure multiple replicas for
automatic failover in case of failure
Kukoc ready infrastructure is the reason
why Google is leading price to
performance on a network inside our
windows VN we intervene throughput can
reach up to 16
the per second on the storage side a PDS
SP was able to deliver up to 40 k ir s--
or without extra cost second Google
cloud platform and Google community is
also flexible platform the per minute
billing gives you fast granularity to
control your cost which is sustained the
UT discard you don't have to make up of
long upfront commitment no lock-in if
you keep using that is coming we are
kicking automatically the customers you
type will key with administrator the
fukken to specify the machine with the
CPU and the memory configuration which
match with enterprise needs we also have
a very flexible license model let's
let's take a look at what the license
model we have so we support the two
different license model be your own
license or payers you go for the plea or
license cosmic on YouTube can choose to
bring over their existing enterprise
agreement with the software we assure
ins for the second server and also other
Microsoft server product like Exchange
Server SharePoint Server to the Google
Cloud the second option is pay as you go
only for what you use Google provides a
pre-configured image with second server
pre-installed together with the permit
bill in an assistant usage usage a
discount this make it's really flexible
option to control your license cost
we talk of the price already line so we
all need to go over the family the
billion and then you to discount I won't
repeat here for sickle civilian price is
consider three part first part is based
William price and also need to pay the
windows license cost and also the second
server license cost I would like to
point out here for the free trial our
free trial available for all the second
server image including the most premium
seconds of Enterprise Edition so how to
create a second server VM the way to
create a secure server VM is very
similar to how you create a regular
Windows virtual machine to find out how
many different circles of the image we
support on Google cloud here's the
g-cloud command you can long the Chuck
here you need to specify that your image
project as Windows Saku cloud
alternatively you can also go to the
application tab on the cloud console you
can find at least odds or the order
available the second server image on the
different windows version we support if
you find a particular configuration you
need but not in the list please reach
out to us performance everyone loved
performance right over the last year we
ship a dozen feature across different
product area to improve the circus ever
experienced on GCE here's feel like a
performance improvement highlight I like
to show you having a clock in the
computer system is important you'll be
even better if the clock can be accurate
and that the cost access clock is low it
turns out is that clear or difficult to
implement
accurate and efficient camera in
virtualized environment most the
implementation come with some
performance cost the silver application
like a circus over to lot of like
sampling take measure the operation
latency so that's why I have an
efficient accommodation is
should be important for silver workload
on a cloudy monument reference TLC is a
hyper-v alignment which allowed virtual
machine to access clock with native
performance without any performance loss
you can also help bring to keep the
clock accurate even when you migrate a
machine among different hosts to support
this feature in cloud environment it's
much more difficult to support this or
on creamy environment we are very proud
to be the first cloud provider to able
to support this feature in our internal
testing when we learn the TPCC benchmark
of course we do a lot of like tunnel
access right we are see the CPU usage
can job up to 20 to 30 percent all these
push all these precious like a CPU cycle
could be used to send seemed more useful
resonant waste on the excess timer
we also made our like a storage tank and
the network stack low efficient I
already talked about the narrow group to
the PD SSD but on scuzzy multi cue is
another feature which is super useful
for our local SSD offering on the
windows it made our virtual storage
adapter more efficient with lower
latency and highest room put since we'll
be deeds the second server stand Edition
by the last year a top question from the
customer is when Google will start of
supported secure server enterprise with
always-on cross beam support so here we
are mission critical staccato walk load
require high availability and disaster
recovery to a Chili's Google cloud
platform support Windows Server fuel
cluster and the always long of a pretty
group all we saw over the bridge group
is secure server flagship hid our
solution allow you to configure multiple
replicas automatically or in case of
failure this replica can be configured
as a breathable allowing to allow you to
offload the read workload and back
so look at the least reference
architecture you need the two custom sub
Network here each custom sub Network
will host one second server instance the
domain controller on the top can be the
same or different sub Network doesn't
matter
you will also need an active directory
as with most typical Windows workload
and we are also promote this domain
controller to the DNS server for post
secure instance we need to join this
active directory and also updated at the
NS DNS setting to use this DNS server
that's important the pack 34 DC DNS will
not work here in order to specify the
class IP and the listener IP when you're
building out your cluster we need to
switch from the DHCP to the static IP
and also configure the IP address using
the GCP advanced of loyal team so that
the packet can be forward to the node
forward to the crack node so in this
reference architecture on the last slide
I talked about a lot like how how you do
that so now I want to talk a little bit
of why why you want to do that what's
the reason behind the ladder first I
like to point out the slide I just show
you it's like a regional actuate
configuration however you can config to
subnet in the same zone or even
configure to different subnet cross
people in the region to make it cross
region a configuration of course if this
cross region you may want to like
configure your secure application using
a synchronous regular pkg instead of
synchronous application to to mitigate
the latency issue second the whole
solution was built in on top like a
multi-site field work cluster because
it's multi-site let's reason we won't we
need two or more customers sub Network
here it's also mean the
can you do support something called a
multi subnet feel were option in the
connecting stream so when you build your
application you specify the connection
to connect those circles to the database
right that's option you just specify its
mean on your clan decide that usually
you need wrong like a a do like 4.5 when
you were like because it is is peanuts
like a faster fit over time in our
internal testing we usually can be
finish this whole fee over in the 10 to
15 seconds let's talk about the
available IP address cloud network
usually is very different from a
traditional like own payment network we
seen on a high level
GCE networking is a big low layer 3
switch the usual feature like a DHCP
broadcast up does not really work the
same way as you expected in the
traditional network the TC network
that's not that's that doesn't know
about the IP address the virtual IP you
config like a listen IP cluster IP you
configure in the cluster so it we are
not automatically at Sony's IP address
to your VM that's why we as we need to
switch from DHCP to static appear and
also used to login to configure this IP
address so the packet can be forward to
the correct sexual instance as we
configure sick a server like a TC
advanced routing for the class IP and
Addison IP by the GCE in working
definition the IP address has to be
outside of the valid TCP sub network
address range because this is
user-defined routing is louisv the
inside the range the loadings are
already pretty fun but however from case
perspective by this Lisa IP has to be in
the same subnet as the primary internal
IP from VL perspective I know is maybe
the confusion that's for example
so here's a typical like a network
configuration we use we have to stop
network here 10.1.1.1 and the ten toe to
toe 1.0 their post / 24 network right
that's how you create your TC subnet
custom stop now to work on the VM side
you can see that for the post VN Lia
have a subnet mask as 255.255.0.0 so
they are both / 16 sub Network which is
also a superset of the TC e sub Network
view when we pick up a listener IP we
just need to pick up an IP address which
is outside of the gc7 or soprano clergy
but inside the V n sub no work mask will
take IP one this new IP one example
right
ten-to-one 2.4 which is outside over
seven l1 10.1.1.10 24 is outside but it
is inside of the subnet mask as defined
by to verify - 4 Phi dot 0 dot 0 which
the same network as the internal IP the
same is also true for the Internet
listener IP - so I want to you
understand this picture
so let's how you pick up a correct
listener IP and a class IP to configure
your always-on cluster for customer to
bring your own license to the Google
cloud there's an extra work they need to
do to follow to get all these Network
change I just talking about they need to
mock the customer image as a multi IP
capable to do that you first create a
disc using a pre-configured google image
then you create a new custom image using
the command commander here specify the
new flag just always a feature flag
called a multi IP subnet
once it is enabled you get all the
network feature I'm talking about in the
previous slide for the pre convicted
image released by Google using the pair
secure license all this has been
automatically taken care of you don't
need the Bali polities so I just talked
a lot about the availa clipping group on
the GCE the men you deploy need a lot of
step is very complicated to be honest
with lab let me handle to my colleague
Anibal he will talk how to deploy it
always on a very big group using
PowerShell efficiently and he will also
show us demo to using a pretty cool to
handle the failure
Thank You Fang so my name is Anibal
Santiago I'm a database engineer with
Google I've been working with speaker
server for at least little more than 20
years I actually started when it was
called Sybase SQL Server and I'm also a
Microsoft Certified solutions associate
in sequel server 2012 and 2014 so with a
Google Cloud SDK you have access to the
powershell commandlets that lets you
manage your google cloud environment we
did a we created a secure server hi
available high availability cluster
using PowerShell and that's a one that
I'll be demonstrating to you the code
that we use to create this cluster is in
github so you will be able just to go to
github see the code downloaded and even
modify it to match your needs after that
I would do a second demo of a cloud
launcher template that will do the same
thing it will it will create a high
availability cluster for you this one is
useful when you want to do like a quick
tour or secure server sa because you
pretty much just click and the whole
environment will be created for you so
let's go to the demo
so first I just wanted to just quickly
show this is the location and you will
see the link later on where the code
that be showing you precise but even
before I go to the actual code let me
just show you a little bit how how if
you are using the Google Cloud console
housing will look like this is after
running it in this case we have two node
cluster SQL one cluster SQL two and a
domain called GC windows one thing I
just wanted to kind of emphasize it's
like thing to be aware like when you set
up your firewall notice how I created
three firewalls and those firewalls idea
how to create myself there's one that I
call allow internal port that just
pretty much allow all traffic between
the three nodes I created one called
allow RDP specifically we want to open
port 3389 now this one is really open it
to the world in your case you'll need to
do that but for simplicity you know I'm
just saying anyone from the work and
really try to do an RDP but just be
aware of that the other thing that we're
going to need when we do our power shell
deployment is open port 59 86 because we
will be using win RM to connect to those
instances so we will also need to open
that port so besides those three
firewalls let me just talk a little bit
about for route later on I know that
Frank talked about this concept but we
will need to clear out in gcp for the
beautiful.i piece of for the windows
failover cluster and the secure server
listener availability group listener so
these are the four router we also create
in general I just wanted to to mention
those two things because those are the
things that you will have to set up once
you get everything running if you're
doing it manually
actually the PowerShell screen will do
that all for you so let me just let's
take a quick look at the code actually
I'm going to minimize this just know so
usually it be the summary about the code
we split the logic into terrific script
files at the end you only need to run
one but we figured that it's easier to
understand just by splitting the logic
into three files the first file that we
call parameters country you just enter
anything that is related to your
environment the name of your node the
IPS the name of your network there's a
space in dirt which specify the name of
the your domain and all that kind of
information so this is the place where
you will customize customize for this
installation the other scrip is the main
one and this is the one that you will
always run is the one that we call
create sequel instance availability
groups on the top of the file we put a
lot of information just to kind of I
just want to maximize this so make it
easier to read so just to show you a
little bit more like you have an idea
what it does now I'm not going to read
each and every line of the code but I
still just going to give you like the
highlights of what it does you will
notice how we everywhere we are using
those command let that unless you're
familiar with the Google Cloud SDK for
PowerShell you know don't have somebody
come and let that you get once you
install the Google Cloud SDK so we go to
the process of first deleting the
instances in the y-axis we will then
create bodies for our two instances back
again you know there's different
examples on how to use the Google Cloud
SDK we go out we then will create the
instances
now every time you create a Windows
instance or actually any instance in
Google cloud they are not available
immediately you usually have to wait a
few minutes for them to be ready so this
part of the code just does that it will
wait until the instances are ready once
the internet are ready we need to you
know generate a password in order to be
able to log on to the server so in this
session we just generate a password now
this is the section where we create
those for route that I talked to you
about and now we mentioned earlier so
you create a route for the beautiful IPS
for the cluster and the listener and
then we start to pretty much connect we
put a mission here just to make sure
that very important that you barely have
port 59 86 open and usually if you done
this is the point where it was fail so
one of the first step that we do when we
when we log on to the server we change
the the network IP to be a static so
this is what we're doing here just
changing the network IP to be static one
thing that happens at the moment that
you change the network IP to be studied
you lose your connection so just to make
a cleaner we remove those session
variables connection variables and we
will recreate them and back again we try
to connect to the server from this point
on is just doing all the other stuff
that you need to do when setting off
speaker server
you know we create folders directories
where we are going to start the database
we open the firewall this is the Windows
Firewall port 5450 50:22 for
availability group port 1433 for seeker
server we enable the clustering feature
of Windows since we are going to need it
later on and finally we are the
computers to the domain once the
computers are added to the domain the
server will restart and the happens
automatically and pretty much one day
added to the domain we are ready to
start creating the cluster so once again
this session we're just waiting for the
computers to restart but once they do we
just bring a message SS we are ready to
create a Windows variable cluster at
that moment we are going to try to
create the window celebrate cluster this
at the point where we decided to put the
logic still in a third file which is the
third father I am going to to show in a
moment it's called equate availability
group dot ps1 why did we put that one
still in a different file if you are
bringing your own license you will not
have to go save a prince all you have to
install it yourself so what the code
will do at this moment it will tell you
if you check the Seekers everything so
if it's not it will tell you
please instruction across harbor and
then it will tell you run this other
script after you are done but if you're
just bringing I mean if you're just
using the pay-as-you-go you know if the
whole thing will continue automatically
now a little bit thing about this other
one discreet that creates a secure
server availability group this script
has no command related to Google Cloud
so this is just a script that you can
use to install and set up a secure
stable availability group so let's say
that on your own environment talking
about you know on premise if you want to
set up and stick your survival ability
group you can just take this section of
the code and you really use it so this
one has nothing to do per se we Google
so let's go to a little bit demo and we
are going to test like a
the plan fell over and unknown plant
fell over before doing that I just want
to show you what is the code that I'm
using to test that struggle over so I'll
just roll like a very simple PowerShell
script that you have a function that
runs a query so it will run any query
that I pass below the query that I'm
just passing to that function is and add
in a record into a table immediately
after and just counting how many wreck
of the table has and when I return on
returning how many records the table has
and also the name of the server the only
reason why I returned the name of the
server just because I want to show you
how the cyber name changes when we do
this trade over and I will also print
and you will see it in a different color
how many seconds it took to do the
failover
so in this blue window is where you find
that little piece of code I'm just going
to start it on the left it tells you
kind of how many freckles are in that
table right now we are connected to
clusters equal two so there are multiple
ways to do a failover I'm going to use
PowerShell but know that you can do that
from Flickr study management studio as
well but this is the command to change
it to clusters to equal one and you will
notice here so let's run it so let's see
how long it takes to do the switch while
you were speck in the blue window is the
name cluster sticker one after doing the
failover so we get the error and it took
ten seconds and we are back now running
in clusters equal one so this is like
testing how you will do like a plan fell
over
so now let's plan to do like an
unplanned failover what I'm going to do
for this one I'm just going to freestyle
clusters to equal one synthethic
currently active node so I already have
to come in here so I'm just do a full
restart of the server what will respect
after we do this restart is that
clusters equal to will become the one
active and if I able to enter the enter
okay so let me minimize that Wow
and in this case you see took five
seconds to to do the switch in this case
you will not see the error the query is
sleeping every one second
so looks like the whole thing happened
within that time and at the end that's
really what the only thing that pretty
much with tests when doing we failover
it is like does it work or does it
doesn't work so let me go now and talk a
little bit more about the other day my
dad said we will do which is the cloud
launch or template so from the Google
console you can launch this cloud
launcher and in here I mean there is a
long list so I do suggest you start SQL
and you will find quickly the one for
seeker server which is this first one it
gives you some information so we'll
continue now for the deployment name you
can choose the name that it gives you or
you can just type a new name you have
the option to choose the zone you will
need to specify a domain that is the
only if you want to do it quickly that
is the only thing that you have you know
you always have to enter so in this case
I'm going to say created on a domain
called DV ing comm below you will see
how you configure your domain controller
in this case I'm just used in excusing
one by one CPU the Windows version is
going to use is going to be Windows
Server 2016 now the template only
supports for now Windows Server 2016 we
are planning to add more versions then
you can choose type of this how big the
disk then is a configuration for secure
server you can choose between two or
three seeker stubborn nodes
same thing how many CPUs also we only
support seeker Server 2016 on Windows
Server 2016 but we are planning to add
the others the option if you just want
to open the firewalls with a public and
click deploy once you click deploy it
would take 30 minutes
but pretty much after 30 min of you have
a working seekers very high availability
cluster for you to test and with that I
will just switch back again to fame to
continue with the presentation thank you
and you bow for the demo now let's talk
about the backup and the disaster
recovery there's a lot of different
options we can choose here first one you
can continue to use beauty in the second
server backup capability you can use the
second Superman you studio T circle or
pause your command alert to do the
backup second you can leverage always-on
I'm gonna breed group to have a multiple
replica ideally across different zoom or
even different in region if one don't
feel the service can just automatically
over the different zone Roxy P is an
adoption the last option I want to point
out here is you can use pity's
percentage snapshot integrated with the
windows one which Shadow Copy Service is
it will pack tiger that backup your
database right with application
consistent and make sure your service is
keep running without interrupted if you
want to know more about the disaster
recovery I want to point point you to
the white paper here isn't written by
our famous seconds of expert in the
brandon in this second server community
and Brenda is also here you're welcome
to talk with him after talk least by the
people discussed the disaster recovery
on for the circus of MTC in greater
detail I mention multi-port analogy
pity's name a short with the VSS
integration is something very powerful
and useful for long in your circle
silver and cocoa computer engine so why
is that so what we assess VSS is
technology including the microsoft
windows which allowing you take a manual
or automatic backup for the volume even
when you use without the VSS the
integration the persistent disk snapshot
it's not aware of any guest state it's
called a crash consistent for a long
lean system it's just like that you put
cable from the wall whatever left on the
disk is your snapshot that's why on
Windows we office the often suggestion
to do a snapshot is to know if your
instance before you take snapshot this
lesson idea for typical operation the
VSS requester here will send a request
to the VSS service and the VA service
will send a notification to all the VSS
writer loosely in the system including
secure services right to tell you hey
I'm gonna take a snapshot please get
yourself ready so all the VSS writer we
are starting like a second server VSS
writer we are starting to coordinate its
internal state for example we need to
flush the internal cash to get itself
into a self-consistent state after
everybody we pride yes to the VSS
service now VSS know everybody's ready
so he will flow to the i/o and they send
the request to the VSS writer say please
take a snapshot so let the workflow
shoot us that's why we can take
application consistency am shot because
the storage system is working with the
application like the circus over to to
the backup by integrated pity snapshot
with the windows VSS you combine the
benefit of the super-fast PD snapshot
which is the consistent feat guarantee
from VSS you get all this without
affecting your Romney instance it's make
it ideal tooth to do the second server
backup let me talk a little bit more for
the other internal component involved
with the PD VSS stuff internally we have
a kook obvious as agent running
and the we'll also have a Google VSS
provider in the every windows VM
instance in the Google compute engine on
the back end when a persistent disk
receive a request to take a snapshot
here the hypervisor we are using
extended weather I'll protocol to send a
signal to the guest without driver the
weather driver will wake up the VSS
agent VSS agent now act just like
requester he will notify the VSS service
to say I want to take a snapshot once
VSS service get the confirmation from
all the writer including seconds over
their service we notified our Google VSS
provider say please take a snapshot top
provider here will not take snapshot
instead he will just send a notification
to the VSS driver the Scaasi driver and
also pack and the PD service say from
kiss possibility we are ready we will be
all ready coordinate our internal state
we are self consistent so you can go
ahead with your snapshot this is already
simplified the high-level overview for
the hot walk flow working together but
you should be get a good idea how
everything working together to do a VSS
enable the snapshot where the internal
logic is quite complicated to actually
implement PD es s indicted snapshot to
use that to take VSS in a Brewster shot
it's actually very easy we add a new
parameter in the existing piece snapshot
API called a DES flash depends on this
parameter is true or false a pity
snapshot workflow with decided was not
to involve or this kiss component to
finish the snapshot by default this flag
has flash flag is a force unless you
specify it explicitly as with any other
GCP feature you have a tip and the way
to use this feature you can use the api
directory you can use g-cloud command
ama and you can also use in cloud
console
as always TOEFL tuning is always
important the part of topping for the
second server after all it's still
second server no matter is the GC or not
ECE so all your existing ology for the
performance tuning for the second server
still most of them still applicable here
I want to point out some difference on
the GCE first there's a different story
optional GC local SSD verse speedy SSD
so which sorts option should I use local
SSD is a faster much faster in a PDS SSD
but it's not as durable as a PDS ST in
general or for the database workload we
suggest you go with the PD SSP if you
want to go with low caste you need to
configure like a using always on a
vertebrate group configure multiple
replicas right to just prepare for the
failure however logo has T is very
useful to put put up your performance a
couple scenario here the first thing is
here you can use local SSD to hold up
your windows page file to speed up the
pitch for the handle for Windows and
then you can also use the local steel to
hold the tempie beii file generally
speaking is good idea to her you have a
dedicated disk to host all your database
so when you format your disk format a
file system on the disk we suggest you
to set the allocation unit size instead
it okay because these people walk past
with underline PD infrastructure on the
open environment usually we heard the
suggestion I get hey keep your data disk
and then data fire and a lock file
separate on different discard for
isolated performance but however on
cloud environment the persistent disk is
already teach with the disk he beggar by
lot of disk and the machine on the back
end so keep the data and the lock in the
same large PD even we are not loose any
performance and they'll make a lie
a lot easier when you do deal with the
sins like a back up again this is a very
high level summary you were interested
you can go to the to linger here for the
the best practice we recommend for the
Google compute engine to some right
today we go over the the basic second
server stuff on Google compute engine
with it
we had deep dive on always long I'm
gonna please group with all the
technology behind the same we revealed
the storage and disaster recovery option
including how to use the VSS enable the
PD snapshot I hope you find that the
information here is useful here's an
additional information you can follow
your interest now to how to run a secure
server on Windows I want to highlight
industry white paper here written by
Brad Brad author
this is very detailed comprehensive
guide to the house how to use the secure
server on the Google compute engine
highly look man it's an odd to talk on
the the conference
unfortunately summit talk it's a config
with this talk if you're interested for
the tool on the windows workload on
Google compute engine
I look at menu go to the tomorrow at the
same time the i/o two to zero deploy
Windows based infrastructure on a Google
compute engine
[Music]
[Music]